foreign
welcome to rational science the only
site on the internet that does physics
rationally directly from
Frankfurt Germany it's nine o'clock here
thereabouts and we have a great day
today we're going to be talking about
what is the language of physics
I mean you know something for you to
think about uh until we get there today
okay try to visualize what you think is
the language of physics okay there are
different opinions and we're going to
try to make that objective
anyways I'm gonna begin uh with a
subject related to Extinction and that
is
what is going to be the last religion on
Earth in other words when Extinction
meets us when we all get to meet our
maker you know
uh will all of us lose our faith will
will we all become atheists at the last
moment
or will we
have more faith more belief hope you
know
which is going to be the case okay and
the reason uh I bring the subject up is
because there was a miracle this week
and so I'm going to talk a little bit
about that Miracle uh that was sent to
the Vatican anyways let's get started
here here you see uh some of the symbols
typical symbols for different religions
and if you're one of those religions
you'll probably recognize the symbol or
what the symbol represents what religion
it represents right
um you know uh different people have
different religions and they have these
icons that representable
okay and uh here are the uh religions by
numbers okay
um this out of the Wikipedia and you can
see that Christianity is number one
religion in the world in general terms
right there are many parts to it for
that matter that's the case for all
other religions as well and it's uh 2.4
billion in one part of the Wikipedia
another site says 2.6 so they're about
two and a half billion people uh are uh
Christians but then you have that broken
up between Catholicism and protestantism
right in some other minor religions like
anglicanism and so on lots of those in
Africa by the way
uh and then you have Islam and uh about
two billion uh you have uh Hinduism 1.2
about half of of uh Islam and about half
of that is for Buddhism only half a
billion okay and you have other minor
religions down at the bottom including
Judaism you know which is
uh
you could say as part of Christianity in
a way right because that's what
essentially the Christians believe right
okay and uh what religion am I well I'll
put that up front I'm not of any of
those traditional religions and I'm not
no longer I used to be an atheist I'm no
longer an atheist either right now I'm a
religion known as scientist okay
scientists physicists specifically and
scientists differ from all these other
religions atheism theism of all kinds
and agnosticism and so on in that we do
not believe in belief okay so we remove
the word belief and that's something
none of these other religions can uh
remove from their uh Notions of religion
and so on yeah religion is belief and
opinion that's what it is okay
okay so uh here we have
um
one site that says what's the future of
religion and it says a growing number of
people worldwide claim that they believe
life to end at death with no God heaven
or divine plan okay and there's
absolutely more atheists around today
than ever before
and finally it says the number of people
that declare themselves religious fell
from 77 to 68. nine percent decrease
between 2005-2011.
self-identified atheists Rose by three
percent
so yes a lot of people are losing faith
at least in the traditional religions
and uh uh question is where does that
lead to is that underway of displacing
all religions all traditional religions
and people finally end up not believing
in God or you know becoming atheists or
agnostics or whatever
and that doesn't seem to be the case
okay here let me show you
um same site says that even though
that's the case that you know
um atheists are gaining
on overall on the planet that's not the
case they're still losing in in as a
proportion of the global population
uh they say that this
Pentecostalism is growing and it's
because there are a lot of people out
there who want to go back to the old
days and they miss traditionalism right
um and a lot of these people also you
know they they want these special things
that they had in the old days like
speaking in tongues which is the subject
matter of today really because that's
what mathematicians do uh when they talk
about you know explanations or physical
interpretations of physics they speak in
tongues that's what it is uh Faith
healing you know and that kind of thing
um and they say that when what
experience usually Inspire complete and
unwavering religious conversion yeah in
other words when when people really
believe uh it's it's when they had an
experience and they say oh you know I
don't know what's out there just in case
I'm going to believe or they do believe
in something unseen untouched you know
uh kind of like a rope
but the Rope we don't believe in the
Rope we call it an assumption so for
those of you who are ready to criticize
it think again the Rope is an assumption
it's not a belief okay
um return to Christianity in its
simplest forms a lot of people again
want to go back to the old days maybe
they even want to hang or uh you know um
Lynch uh people who do not believe like
they do that used to happen in the past
as well okay so I don't know if they
want to go that far okay anyways what is
the future of religion according to this
site again okay and it says by the year
2050 the following is set to occur if
current trends continue very big if
there okay the global population of
Muslim Believers will almost equal the
number of Christians worldwide in other
words uh Muslims they're growing at a
faster rate than Christians atheists
agnostics and those who have no
affiliation with any religion will
comprise a declining proportion of the
global population even though such
bodies are increasing in numbers in
countries such as U.S and France so you
have all these countries like in the
western world where atheists are
becoming more and more but compared to
the global population uh they're going
to become a smaller percentage so that's
a an irony it's only the advanced
Nations now the only thing thing I would
say against that is that you know as
time goes by you have
people who have access to the internet
and they may change their opinions
faster than they can be drawn into one
of the traditional religions the other
thing that I want to mention I don't
think we'll make it to the year 2050
okay so that's another issue so I don't
think we have to worry too much about
these Trends uh these for 30 years maybe
10 15 at most I don't know I can't tell
you for sure but I don't give it too
much time uh humans you know on the
planet the global population of
Buddhists will reach approximately the
same number as in 2010 will it's Hindu
and Jewish populations will increase in
size compared to today
Muslims will comprise 10 of the overall
European population and I do believe
that one because uh like here in
Frankfurt I think I would say that
one-third in fact I think there's a
number for that about one-third of the
population is uh of Turkish descent or
Arab descent in general descent in
general and so you know I would think
that yeah the the Muslims will be taking
over and muscling the Christians aside
basically you know the the traditional
German religions you know like
Lutheranism and so on India will retain
Hindu majority but will also boast the
largest population of Muslims of any
other country overtaking Indonesia
simply because of the big population
that India has right Christians will
decline for from uh from more than three
quarters of the population in the U.S to
two-thirds Judaism no longer retaining
its title as the largest non-Christian
religion Muslims will be more numerous
in the U.S than Jewish people four of
every 10 Christians worldwide will be
based in sub-Saharan Africa
how's ever a trend okay or a set of
Trends and again I'm not sure we're
going to reach the year 2050 so we may
not have to worry about these
30-year long-term trends may not happen
um and I can't say for sure okay I'm not
going to say that I know for a fight I
don't have a crystal ball I'm just
saying I don't I don't have a feel for
us living another 30 years me for sure I
won't live another 30 years but the
question is whether Humanity will live
another 30 years okay and uh
some of the things that are going on in
the world today I think will accelerate
you know the time we meet our maker okay
humans you know okay so uh here's uh
what the article said it was uh from
Hartford current Hartford Connecticut
says a possible Miracle at Connecticut
Church being investigated by the Vatican
yeah and then uh I'm not sure it's a
miracle in the sense that you know you
have um quantum mechanics and it says
that particles can appear from the void
from nothing and uh obviously the
universe appeared from nothing as well
they don't say it that way but they
insinuated some some do like you know
you have Larry uh what's his name I
can't remember his last name now uh um
and he he believes that something came
from nothing and there are a lot of uh
so-called physicists mathematical
physicists who believe the same thing
and this is more or less what happened
in this uh Church it says the results of
an investigation into the reports of a
possible Miracle at such and such church
have been sent to the Vatican what did
they find well on March 5 the Reverend
so-and-so pastor of such and such uh
Church there which includes St Thomas
reported that during Holy Communion a
lay person Distributing hosts had found
that the Wafers had multiplied in the
suborium Okay now what's a host uh let's
clarify that looks like this it's a
little wafer that they put in your mouth
it's a wafer of unleavened uh bread made
with wheat flour usually circular in
shape and the term ostia which is a
synonym of host uh derives from the
Latin hostia meaning sacrificial victim
a sacrifice made to a deity
okay so uh that's what uh happened there
the host the osteos multiplied and God
duplicated himself in the civilorium uh
said so and so right God provides and
it's strange how God does that and that
happened okay and so they say that this
miracle happened and they sent the
miracle or the report to the Vatican so
that I guess the pope my RG friend uh
Pope Frankie uh that he could bless it
or you know call it a miracle and this
is the specific
um thing that happened inside the church
okay it says let me remove this
a second here says the poem says and as
time went on the hosts were being
distributed fellow was giving the host
of people to the congregation right
and then all of a sudden the individual
looked down and all of a sudden there
were there were there's uh more hosts in
the seboria and kept giving the hosts
out there's even more hosts in the
sevoria kept giving hosts out and
there's even more hosts in the Savory so
by the time everyone received communion
and I came back up to the altar there
was the same amount if not more hosts
that I gave the individual in the
civiloria
so there were more like like the trace
you know giving fish to the people to
the crowds this was more or less the
same thing he gave out the host the
osseus and what happened was that he
kept getting more and more hosts in his
uh his little thing here in seboria and
Crowley said also during the um homily
uh neither he nor the Eucharistic
Minister had been praying for such a
miracle but he said it was something to
think about
well I don't know I mean maybe it was
the devil who was doing all this I mean
how do we know it was God or the devil I
mean maybe it was the devil
uh for some reason that I cannot imagine
I mean I don't know why God would I
don't know what why the devil wouldn't
do it and uh they say well it's because
they wanted to people to have more faith
and so they made that magic trick where
more of these hosts come you know into
being
again from empty space I guess like in
quantum mechanics right so you have more
of them and so people say oh now I
believe because we had 10 hostages we
had 100 people we were able to give
positives to every person in there right
all these hosts and it turns out that I
had the fellow has some left over and he
only had 10 to begin with so yeah that
that is a miracle no no doubt about it
if it's true right maybe the guy was
drunk maybe he didn't count property
yeah I don't know
okay
okay so um so here's the issue the issue
is
um you know what Saint Augustine uh said
that God could be outside the universe
right and he's uh he's doing all these
miracles from outside he even made the
miracle of creating the uh the earth and
the universe itself
and I got a problem with this uh under
the Rope model okay we we cannot
tolerate uh God being outside the
universe for a couple reasons and let's
go over some of these okay here's one
okay here you have God outside the
universe the universe is just a single
closed loop thread according to the Rope
model that's the Assumption okay and so
we have a problem because God is not in
touch he's not part of that uh thread
and if God is not part of that thread he
has no way of contacting us
okay the only way he can contact us uh
is if he's somehow in Con in in contact
with the thread and as you can see he's
isolated completely in this image here
and that's essentially what uh Saint
Augustine was saying in other words uh
according to Saint Augustine God is not
part of the universal thread the single
thread okay and we're saying that that
thread is what makes up all of matter
all the atoms and all the
interconnections that have this uh DNA
like uh form we call it a rope that
connects every two every any two atoms
in the universe okay so if God wants to
be part of the universe if God wants to
exist God has to be part of the thread
okay if God is not part of the thread he
has no way to contact us let alone us
contacting him okay
um that means we're we're not in
communication with God and God is not in
communication with us okay and then the
other thing that God would have to
explain is how he created this threat
how he created the universe right
everything including the Earth
um that he created from nothing I mean
what was there before the thread was
there absolutely all that Blackness all
that nothingness is that what was there
before then
and so the person who proposes that God
created the universe has to answer that
question otherwise he has no case in
science and physics okay and uh you know
you might say well you know I don't know
uh God knows only how he did it
so here's the question for you here's
God right he comes down to earth okay
we're going to assume that he's part of
the thread now okay he comes down to
earth and he explains to you how he
created something from nothing
okay do you think you would understand
his manufacturing process do you think
if he explained if God himself sat down
there at the park bench and said look
let me tell you how I created something
from nothing
do you think we would understand
whatever he explains
okay and I suggest that we would we have
the intelligence to understand anything
that anyone in this in this universe
wishes to explain to us I mean you know
you can have the Klingons come over and
they can explain something in their part
of the world or part of the universe and
they say look this is how we do things
over there this is uh some um technology
that we have there okay can you explain
it to us yeah and the guy would say look
this is what it looks like and this is
how it works and this is how we made it
you would be able to explain all those
things to you why wouldn't you
understand it
you know what is it that you would
understand
okay and and again the issue here is uh
with God is the same thing if God comes
down from heaven or from wherever he is
The Fifth Dimension and he sits down and
he talks to you personally you know you
know one-on-one and he explains how he
created something from nothing
why wouldn't you understand them
that's the million dollar question for
you okay
anyways regarding what's going on in the
universe when uh I'm sorry on Earth uh
among humans okay here we have uh one uh
headline says EU the European Union U.S
to pledge joint action over China
concerns that says that all these uh
folks politicians Etc they got together
here in uh Brussels and we'll pledge
joint action to tackle concerns focused
on China got them very nervous China's
on the news every second about
non-market practices and coordinate uh
their export controls on semiconductors
and other Goods at a meeting this month
a draft statement shows okay so uh these
folks uh want to do want to want to
block uh China in different ways
and China promises to take uh you know
uh counter measures okay so I don't know
if that's good for the world the fact
that we're dividing
um
the world economics in two parts okay
assuming that's what's happening
sometimes you know the politicians do
mislead you for whatever reasons they
have but if it's real if if they end up
doing it and they say we're not going to
give you this because we're afraid
you're going to use it for military
purposes and then the Chinese come back
and say then we're gonna not gonna buy
this other stuff from you or whatever or
we're going to put tariffs or whatever
counter measures they take
then it's going to be a uh a pretty bad
world you know these things are not good
be nice if we all cooperate but uh here
we're talking about absolute competition
which is what Mother Nature likes Mother
Nature doesn't like lions reaching an
agreement and saying look you take that
Harem I'll take this one no you got to
fight for it there's got to be
competition Mother Nature loves that
stuff she loves killing she loves
fighting
murder cannibalism she likes all that
stuff okay so uh we have to fight and
and uh but fighting does not conduce in
this sense to a monopoly it usually
conduces to Extinction you know and not
necessarily because we throw the bombs
at each other but we destroy the global
economy once you destroy the global
economy there is no future okay
can't restart it back up again okay and
here so there's one fella at least uh
Economist who uh Nobel Prize by the way
uh who warns against this he says hasta
U.S policies on China risks splitting
the world into two blocks
urging the West to offer investment not
lectures to developing countries we may
be in some kind of strategic competition
but that doesn't mean that we have to be
quite so hostile okay Washington is
attempting to limit Chinese influence on
critical Supply chains and this cannot
be explained simply by concerns over
beijing's political system we have many
quote uh friends right who are
authoritarian but what we don't like is
the economic competition and political
competition in other words uh you know
you've got countries like Saudi Arabia
they've got an authoritarian system
United States is not completely dead set
against them in fact they were quite
friends until maybe uh a couple years
ago right but until then uh they were
very good friends and it was an
authoritarian system which is continues
to be you know an authoritarian system
uh so it's not but the United States has
very little to fear from smaller
countries like Saudi Arabia China that's
a different story
so it says the West is investing very
little in developing economic economics
and compared to countries like China now
there's China is now getting into these
developing countries uh giving them
money loans Etc in the west is not doing
its share of of that process and so
China is gaining influence by you know
introducing its uh money right
especially bribing money buying them off
or whatever
we give them lectures about what to do
and they the Chinese give them money
yeah that's the difference the US is not
present in Latin America and Africa and
the Chinese are getting in there right
well we say we're competing we're not
doing the investment politics in America
has gotten into a very strange place
and I think uh the issue there is that
um the United States doesn't have that
much disposable
money to be able to loan it around it's
got problems of its own uh China's
growing twice as fast as the United
States and so at some point if that's
projected forward you know they're going
to catch up and so that's what the
United States and the Western World you
know Europe included uh fear okay and so
this is where we're at and then you have
the war in in Ukraine which is not good
for Humanity either and all I can tell
you there is uh we don't know what's
going on there because the military on
one side and the military and the other
side they just give you lies because
they have to you know have cheerleaders
for their side and so you don't really
know what's going on
and this week they said well look we've
uh made some gains in this little town
called bakmut and the problem there is
uh you know it could be twofold maybe
it's real right maybe they made some
games the ukrainians maybe it's uh what
happened to you know Napoleon and uh
Hitler and uh you know where where you
had uh fun Poppin you know he he went
with his army over there and they kind
of
you know allowed him to come in same
with Napoleon and then they had this
pincer movement where they slaughtered
them and so sometimes these are War
tactics and so they say oh we're losing
we're losing it turns out they're not
losing they're running away hoping you
know for the other side to be encircled
and so and both sides know this okay so
uh some are very cautious in saying you
know we're not gonna fall into that trap
and the other guys are saying uh you
know are kind of welcoming men saying
yeah yeah we're losing uh you're beating
us and maybe that's not true either so
we don't really know what's going on
over there that's the reality because uh
whatever you get from either side is
just a bunch of Lies okay that's they're
just cheerleading their own teams that's
all they're doing
okay let's move on to a subject that um
uh we touched upon last week and it
turns out that um
uh a lot of people had lots of questions
about and that is gravity how does
gravity work and yeah people want to
know want to understand uh oh gravity
works and everybody has their own idea
of course and the only one we're going
to reject here is all ideas based on
particles okay particles meaning
um
pressure
okay
um no such thing okay you can't produce
uh pool with push okay that's the issue
okay so keep that in mind so one fellow
says the following says no bill that's
how gravity is gravity is not a pull
Force okay yeah uh we agree and that's
because he did not understand that okay
he thinks that we are saying it's a pull
force and I've said it many times
already uh it's not a pull we use the
word pull okay because we are pulled as
as an object we're pulled downwards
towards the center of the Earth but
we're saying that every atom in our body
is only under tension with the atoms on
the earth the Rope is always under
tension there is no pull along the rope
and I don't know how many times to
emphasize that and people keep thinking
of pull because we're used to using the
word pull I just want to clarify one
more time one atom does not pull on
another atom okay there's no pull along
the Rope there's tension tension is not
a pull like it is in a religion of
mathematics okay so let's just keep that
in mind okay but says even when you
think you are pulling the air into your
lungs you are not
okay it says the air is simply flowing
from a region of high pressure to a
region of low pressure
all you are doing is letting the air
rush into your lungs to fill the volume
by stretching your rib cage I'm actually
explaining it with a real mechanism
no you're not what you're doing is
describing and you don't understand that
it takes a long time for you to
understand that you're not explaining
anything you're just describing and uh
well let me just finish this up says
it's the same with gravity electricity
and magnetism but the field is not air
okay the fluid is not air okay it's not
some magical pull a pull is illogical
and irrational
well this fellow doesn't know how to
argue it doesn't know how to talk okay
in science if you're going to say it's
illogical and uh
illogical you have to explain why you
think it's irrational logic but it
leaves it there in his opinion but he
doesn't tells how he justifies that
opinion so again it shows you these are
people who are not qualified to do
science because uh they don't I mean if
you're going to say something back it up
and these people don't back it up they
just say something because it sounds
good to them okay
and so what is the problem I have with
uh like this well let's go with that uh
pulling
um the flow from a region of high
pressure to a region of low pressure or
from high density to low density right
so they have this idea that the
molecules even out in the container
right this is what they've been taught
and it's ingrained in them so much that
they probably will not understand the
argument that I'm going to make now okay
so it's only for intelligent people what
I'm going to say now okay not for people
like this gentleman okay and here it is
here you have the Earth and you have the
different levels of Earth of air around
the earth you have 760 Tor which is
approximately you know it's um that's
the value of uh our pressure here on
Earth at sea level more or less okay 750
760. and then as you go out you can see
the levels drop you get to a very fine
air and when you you go even further you
get to a point where you get to
Universal or you could say solar system
level pressure and it's a very very
light pressure there's hardly any
particles there on the moon it's been
measured at 10 to the minus 12 10 to
minus 11 10 to minus 12 torr yeah I like
the word tour because I use that
um
unit because that's what I'm familiar
with that's the one we used in
semiconductor processing it's not
probably the correct one for this but
it's good enough because the important
thing is not
what that number means it's just that I
just want you to see that there's hardly
any particles on the moon on the uh in
the atmosphere of the Moon okay maybe
some dust that is stirred up or whatever
and then here you have the solar wind on
the left hand side and that's in the
10th of the minus 13 tour in other words
the solar wind is even finer
less particles per cubic meter than on
the moon so in the moon you have a
little more pressure you could say than
uh with a solar wind
and so the question is why doesn't all
that high density air why doesn't it
dissipate throughout the Universe why is
it stuck to the Earth
that's the question this fellow has to
answer okay here you have high density
close to the center to the Center of the
Earth right close to our surface and you
have low density As you move out
and you can see we don't need a
container which is another thing that
these people have in mind they say oh
you need a container to have pressure
you know they have this idea that
particles hit against the walls and
create this pressure yeah that's true in
a chamber I worked with those quite a
bit in my life you know but here we're
talking about something that has no
container you know the Earth is not
contained immediately you know maybe you
could say It's contained within space
time the edges of space time we can even
concede that but between the Earth and
the moon there's there's no object no
container
that contains the air on the earth and
so the question is why doesn't this air
dissipate and just flow out into space
if it's like he says that it goes from
high density to low density that's all
he's got to explain okay and I hope he
doesn't say well because of gravity
[Laughter]
no kidding
okay so that's the issue
so this notion that he says that uh air
or molecules or whatever flows from uh
high density to low density that's not
an explanation that's a description
please explain the cause okay what
causes that to happen yeah that's that's
the question okay here you have another
fellow along similar lines he says talks
talks about the solar wind he says you
forgot to draw the solar wind in your
absurd little animation aha do you
dispute that the solar wind exists if
not what is your justification
okay and and again all we can do is uh
point to this that the solar wind is 10
to the minus 13 torr okay there's
nothing there okay essentially we can
that's probably the level the maximum
level we can achieve here on Earth with
all our uh uh pumping
equipment okay you can maybe reach 10 to
the minus 13. we we used to work in a
minus uh seven range and so this is
about twice in in orders you know what
we used to work in the San Martin Luther
industry so we're talking about
something the solar wind is not a wind
these people think it's a hurricane or
something the solar wind is nothing okay
and so the first issue is that you know
a lot of these flat earthers say uh oh
hold it but why don't the astronauts get
uh killed with all these bullets that
are flowing through space and again they
think that it's it's a hurricane or you
know uh some kind of uh tornado or
something who knows the other thing that
they confuse is that they confuse the
solar wind which is particles where the
magnetosphere which is made of threads
the
magnets you know Magnus uh the magnetic
field so-called field that's uh
comprised of threads that are swinging
around and again that's not matter in
the sense that an atom is matter so
anything uh like atoms and above will
call particles and anything below is
just these threads and so you know the
solar wind does not really consist of
magnetism okay which is threads it just
consists of particles and they're very
very few particles in the solar wind so
yeah we don't include it because it's
irrelevant to uh gravity that's why we
don't include it it's uh and again it's
just so this individual is ignorant of
of the basics of physics okay and same
fellas as the following says there's
something ironic about a rope theorist
making fun of string theory
they listen and they say oh rope that
sounds like string like wire like uh
cable or any of those words you know
synonyms and so they say it's the same
thing you're laughing at another guy
who's proposing the same thing as you
are
well there are so many errors with uh
with what this fellow is thinking and so
let's uh let's put them up there here we
have them rope is not a theory
rope is known as a hypothesis okay an
assumption theory is an explanation a
rope is an object okay God is not a
theory God is an assumption that's a
thing okay for those of you who think of
God as a thing right now as the guy with
a magic wand who made the Earth that's
different than God the concept you know
oh God is love oh God is intelligence
now you now you've made God into an
abstract concept and that's what you're
praying to if that's what you pray to
right
um so we have to distinguish Concepts
from objects okay and we're saying that
rope is an object okay
uh
then we have here rope is a hypothesis
again an assumption string uh it's not
an explanation
okay and uh string is one D
which is you know takes it out of the
realm of objects there's no such object
that is one D or Zero D like in
mathematical physics okay in
mathematical physics you have
singularities you have points and
they're all Zero D no Dimension
whatsoever they call these things and
then you have one D like lines or
strings which are again lines
mathematical lines which they convert
into physics physical things you know uh
so a string is not uh like the Rope the
Rope is 3D okay Freedom dimensional okay
let's get that right the string is one
dimensional because it's a mathematical
concept it's not a thing
they're not going to do anything with
this string they will but it's all Bs
because it's a concept One D okay 1D
concept
strength theory is a math description
okay it's not a physical entity okay and
they should call it the loopy Theory why
because they they have these Loops which
I showed the other day I'm going to show
it one more time here uh that they break
and they weld
you know constantly you're constantly
welding and opening up magically because
they don't explain the process I mean we
don't know if they're sewed together uh
they uh paste it together you know glue
you know they don't explain the process
of why these things open up and close up
okay that's different than the Rope
model OKAY a rope model it's just a robe
it just uh torques okay that's different
than you know I mean there's nothing
there that is magical in that sense that
we're not saying that the rope breaks
and comes together or anything like that
okay but that's what they're saying in
string theory okay and Luke's break and
weld uh you know what's the mechanism
again gravitons uh reside in the Hindu
in in a hidden Dimension remember
what's his name
um Brian Cox he was saying that uh the
reason we don't see gravitons is they go
to different dimensions
how do you pull with gravitons okay
that's the other question you got to
answer okay show me the mechanism that
you're going to use to uh you know to
pull with particle with discrete
particles how do you pull and again you
can't say high density to low density
you know this absorption uh idea that
these people have because they cannot
explain it with that okay
and here let me show you what Matt uh
Dowd said the other day concerning this
and he said look this is a pair of kinks
in the string are whipped back and forth
by the oscillating string and the
incredible mass in these Kinks causes
them to radiate gravitational waves and
so they slowly Decay away and what did
Brian Cox tell us well he says they
Decay away into unseen Dimensions
okay so uh you figure out what they're
trying to say there looks like that does
look like magic that is Magic and that's
what you receive from the establishment
okay same fella says
if oceans only push one way then what
about Riptide
poor people
okay let me show you a Riptide here uh
I'll illustrate it for you okay here's
the riptide okay
here's a river and the question is is
the river pulling or pushing on the logs
okay where's the riptide there okay and
the same with the riptide that this Pho
is talking about in other words the
riptide uh
that's produced by the moon okay uh you
know the the tide goes back the question
is are you being pulled or are you being
pushed by water particles
okay is there a vacuum being produced
and that's why you fall okay these are
the questions you need to answer and so
let me show you here what the what
causes the tides that's where this
fellow should begin so that he can talk
intelligently and here it is you this is
from NASA and you can see what causes
the tides and it's the moon they they
say it's gravity whatever gravity is the
moon is pulling through nothing at the
at the water okay and the question is
how does the moon do that okay is the
moon in contact with the water
or is it black magic
meaning the Moon is not in contact but
somehow affects it from action at a
distance you know from
uh Again by Magic
so so that's the first question you got
to answer he's got to answer how does
the moon produce the tide okay that's
where he's got to explain the pull that
you see there okay and here's uh what
causes the tide you can see different
Tides different parts of the air and The
Sun Also plays a role in there okay
because uh you know when you have the
Sun and the Moon on the same axis well
you have uh probably more pull like
there okay uh whereas when you have it
on the other side well they're pulling
in different directions 90 degrees to
each other okay so you know that gives
you an idea what causes the tides how
it's done how Mother Nature does that
okay and that's what you really with
this phone needs to understand first
explain the tides then you then you can
explain the Rip Tide you know how you
get pulled into the water if that's what
you're what's happening are you being
pushed by the water are you being pulled
by the water you know like the logs
there
okay and uh Saint Paul says uh insistent
he says passing your hand through the
Rope sounds like black magic to me
yeah because there's always thinking of
touch okay they've got touch in their
minds okay and he continues
and he says the phone he says connecting
objects with ropes does not explain
where the pull between objects comes
from you can try it yourself by
connecting two dead elephants with ropes
nothing will happen again uh has all
these Notions of touch he he has to
introduce touch in there when we say you
can't touch the rope okay the twirling
rope animation makes no sense given that
the Earth does not spin on an axis
pointing towards the Sun and vice versa
you can't recreate that animation in
reality using real spheres and ropes and
animation that is not consistent with
reality is worthless
and so what can we say uh we got to show
them you know
um what
um well the same argument that we use
against Einstein okay here it is okay
here you have uh different parts
different planets okay you have the Moon
and the Earth they're on the same axis
you know so the moon causes
um these uh blackouts which we call
eclipses right because it stands behind
at some point it stands between the
Earth and the Sun okay and so it it
essentially uh the moon goes
approximately on the same plane as the
Earth when you move to Oberon which is
the one of the moons of uh Uranus uh the
moon
goes over the pole of Uranus towards the
Sun
and away from it not not like uh the
moon there our moon which goes
approximately on the same plane as the
equator more or less not close to it
this one goes over the poles and then
when you look at
um Sharon the moon of
um Pluto what you see is that it's got
this Bullseye pattern with respect to
the sun okay and my point here is that
you know the spin of the planet is
unrelated to
the threads the to the ropes that are
being that are holding every atom of the
Earth for example to every atom of the
sun the sun throws the Earth around
itself that's the orbit but it has it
that's not what causes the spin okay and
again what you see in these other uh
cases again has to do with the spin of
the planet in other words the Earth uh
spins the Moon around itself
in other words the moon orbits the earth
because the Earth swings it around the
same goes with Uranus and the same goes
with Sharon
okay Pluto and Sharon so the spin itself
is not the cause of uh or in Reverse you
can you can't see that the Rope causes
the spin okay uh it's it's uh the fact
that every atom on Earth is connected to
every atom of the sun only explains the
orbit of the earth not why the Earth
spins on its axis which it spins at a
what is a 24 degree angle or whatever
okay so you got to separate spin from
orbit okay
Val has to understand these basic things
of uh physics and he doesn't he's just
you know thinking that he's making a
great uh contribution to science by
criticizing something that he doesn't
understand
okay here we have another fellow and he
says technically there are many things
we've said that just move and nothing is
in contact with them
aha so he's saying that you know things
move but not always is there something
in contact with them okay Adam is moving
in the void from uh Greek thought they
move and nothing is contacting or
forcing them to okay well we could uh go
on and on with uh several things that
are wrong with his train of thought
let's just get to the basic one and that
is the following uh when you see the
Earth rolling around the Sun
okay
um
if something did not deflect
change the direction of the earth the
earth would just go straight so yes
moving but if nothing changes it nothing
comes in contact with the Earth it would
continue to go straight and straight out
of the solar system but that's not what
we observe or what we measure or
whatever that's what we know we
understand
that's not this this description that we
have out there again this is what we
have we have that the Earth continues to
roll around in circles more or less
around the Sun okay and so the question
is what causes the Earth to change
direction that's the million dollar
question
so this is a simple one that he should
be able to answer because he's saying
nothing comes in contact with the Earth
well if nothing comes in contact why is
it changing its direction if Newton says
unless something comes in contact with
the Earth okay or any object that's
moving in in a given Direction uh it
will not change that direction the only
reason it changes that direction is
because something a thing comes in
contact with the Earth okay and so what
con what is it that comes in contact
with the Earth well here you have it
okay it's the threads the ropes okay
and uh so the sun swings the Earth
around by these ropes every atom on the
earth is connected to every atom of the
Sun and now we can explain very easily
why the Earth
changes its direction every second okay
it moves more or less in a circle
okay and so now you have that something
the something is ropes you don't want to
put ropes in there no problem tell me
what what physical object forces the
Earth to change direction
and you say well nothing because we
can't see we can't touch anything out
there and then what you're doing is
you're doing black magic that is black
magic because you're saying there's
action at a distance and there's nothing
in physical contact with the skin of the
earth and yet the skin of the earth is
moving in a circle it's changing its
direction constantly
okay so that's what you got to answer
hopefully you don't say space time
because space-time is what a concept
okay a bunch of coordinates that's all
the space time is and we're getting
there also here we have if you got a
relative if you got a relative's video
to criticize uh here okay I got sorry I
got a relative yeah I've seen this video
and I've seen others similar to that and
they talk about
um
3D scenario for space time rather than
the 2D scenario okay so let's uh let's
go with that so that you know what I'm
talking about okay here it is
I went to the site and this is what the
site has and the important thing here is
that it has 2.3 million views and the
site itself has uh almost you know half
a million subscribers
and the question is uh with 113
000 right upvotes and this is what
they're going to show they're going to
show this uh 3D space time and instead
of the earth just weighing it down what
you're going to have is all this uh 3D
space-time moving towards the center of
the earth that's what they're going to
show okay and so you can see how many
people get sucked in by this nonsense
and they just believe it and they don't
even know what they're believing in okay
they just tangentially capture some idea
there and say okay I understand what
they're saying they don't understand
squat okay here it is okay so here's the
2D space time okay the typical one you
know you have the little earth going
around the Sun and and this these fellas
are saying that's not the way it really
works okay that's silly you know the
bending of space time downwards okay
and uh by the way this is what all uh
mathematical physics physicists believe
in that's what they describe the but
this one says oh I know more than all of
them put together because that's not the
case this is ridiculous you cannot
really use this as an analogy for what's
happening out there okay so how is he
going to show the rotation then
okay because that's what we want to
understand okay we understand why the
Earth doesn't go flying out of the solar
system and of course he's not going to
explain that he's just going to try to
explain gravity to you and he said no
gravity Works in a different way it
works this way and here you see it he
illustrates it he says look the Earth is
sucking all this space time
out of space-time out of the space I
don't know out of the fourth dimension
Fifth Dimension sucking it into its
Center okay it just absorbs it and
that's what all these people have in
mind they say it absorbs particles it
absorbs space time it absorbs gravitons
whatever it's absorbing it's all going
towards the center of the earth okay
because you know you let go of your pen
and falls to the center of the ear so he
says this explains it see that would
explain why the pen falls to the Earth
to the Center of the Earth okay so uh
let's see if they can answer this first
you can see that he's not explaining why
the Earth doesn't flow out of the solar
system which is the main point the other
one explains why the Earth doesn't go
out of the solar system it's ridiculous
but it explains that it says look you
know the Earth is rolling or sliding
along this time warp no the time is
Warped around it and the Earth the skin
of the earth isn't coming coming in
contact with this warped time okay
that's the answer here you won't see
that there's no explanation for why the
Earth doesn't go out of the solar system
but then here's a situation uh here we
have all these planets okay and stars
whatever you want to put in there okay
you can put anything you want and what
it's doing every one of them is sucking
towards the center of the planet okay
and so the question is you know if it's
going towards the center of the planet
uh where's the slack coming from okay
that's that's uh you know is it pulling
space-time out of what you know because
they're all pulling towards themselves
uh are they ripping space-time apart is
that what's Happening Here and again uh
what you need to understand above all is
that uh you know what you're staring at
really when you're looking at all these
lines is you're you're looking at this
you're looking at coordinates which I
discussed the other day that's that's
what space time is it's a just a set of
coordinates okay and that's what these
people are saying is being sucked in
coordinates that's what you're staring
at that's what all those lines are okay
and so you're looking at you're looking
at this
and that's being sucked in and so the
question is you know here you have space
time this is what another fellow
Illustrated right and you have the
SpaceTime being dragged towards the
center it doesn't explain where that's
extra space time is coming from okay are
you ripping it from space time itself
from what and then it doesn't explain at
all why the earth goes does not fly out
of the solar system you know how do you
explain that part okay how does this
explain that the orbit of the Earth
and so yeah and people just put the
likes and oh I liked it I think I
thought uh they were right you know the
two-dimensional version of space-time is
irrational
but this one's more irrational they
don't realize that
okay so let's get on to the subject
matter of today which is what is the
language of physics okay and you know
lately you know we've been looking at uh
the universal movie okay which is uh
this thing here it's a tool and we're
saying that all these words uh the ones
that are static Concepts belong in a
single frame of the universal movie uh
whereas uh any of the bottom ones there
those are Dynamic Concepts why we call
them dynamic because they take up at
least two frames in a universal movie
you need at least two locations to talk
about motion position the position of
mathematical physics by the way uh ether
field energy any of those those are all
Dynamic Concepts okay and so we've been
talking about some of these words there
are several more that we covered in the
last few weeks okay
so uh you know that's where we stand
that's physics okay because we're
defining our terms we're saying whether
it's a static concept or a dynamic one
and we're justifying it
the mathematicians are saying Bill
you're wasting your time
okay okay why am I wasting my time okay
let's find out okay you're wasting your
time because this is the language of
physics mathematics okay here you have
one site and says mathematics has a
vital role to play as the language of
physics as such departed plays must be
subservient to the physics
and these are not the only people who
say it here's uh just in case you know a
little more volume there to help them
out okay this is another site uh
nut okay that says with a concept of
differentiation integration and
differential equations any Theory could
be explained
Theory can be explained with an equation
I'd like to see them do that I mean I
don't know what they're talking about
but you cannot explain with an equation
anything I cannot explain you know why
this pencil Falls the Cause right with
an equal with an equation I can tell you
how fast it goes or that sort of thing
and it's not going to tell me what
caused it and that's that's what an
explanation is but these people don't
understand that okay all the laws
governing the nature could be expressed
based on mathematical equations yeah
laws maybe whatever that is in
mathematical mathematics mathematics
mathematical physics right
uh yeah over there they can talk about
laws there are no laws in physics and
physics all we have are explanations
okay hence mathematics can be regarded
as the language of physics so these
people believe in that mathematics is
the language of physics as well okay and
just in case we have one more okay here
it is
says mathematics as structural language
of physics physical thought and it's a
paper this fellow wrote from Brazil okay
mathematics is definitely uh lodged in
the core of physics hence becoming uh
evident when uh encountering the
products of its scientific activities
and it says mathematics enters the
physical discourse by means of functions
equations Graphics vectors tensors etc
etc and I don't know how he justified
that he's just saying it does
okay I guess he just memorized this in
high school or college and just spitting
it out you know like poetry oh into the
important role of mathematics has played
in the organization of physical theories
some authors view its adoption as a
Criterion of rationality and not merely
as indicative of conventionality or
empiricism
so these folks they've been educated or
brainwashed or whatever you want to call
it to believe that mathematics is the
language of physics
and I'm saying that you know my language
of physics is a little different than
theirs because it doesn't involve any
equations
and so you say well where did they get
that idea
okay and here's uh probably the source
okay her name Galileo in the 17th
century and he wrote in his book you
know uh dialogue concerning two new
Sciences 1638 a couple years uh four
years before he died
and Galileo says the following says
philosophy meaning uh philosophy of
nature right is written in that great
book whichever is before our eyes I mean
the universe but we cannot understand it
if we do not first learn the language
and grasp the symbols in which it is
written uh-huh yeah which one is that
the book is written in mathematical
language and the symbols are triangles
etc etc right without whose help it is
impossible to comprehend a single word
of it without which one wanders in vain
through a dark Labyrinth
mathematics is the language in which God
has written the universe and believe me
if I were again beginning my studies I
would follow the advice of Plato and
start with mathematics so this is
probably the source or at least one of
the sources uh the other one could be
Descartes Rene Descartes uh all these
people you know they they thought just
like Plato and Aristotle and Euclid all
these other foes from from the days of
the Greeks they really thought
mathematics was a synonym of physics
okay because they said this is the
language in which we represent
and what are they representing they're
representing descriptions they're not
representing explanations okay there's a
difference between a description and
explanation and that's what they never
figured out that if physics is
explanation it's got nothing to do with
math which is only only only
description okay so there's a difference
between those okay and so uh we look up
uh definition of physics what is physics
what do people think physics is and just
in case I'm gonna
point to uh official sites okay because
otherwise people say oh you got that
from the Layman out there he doesn't
know okay so let's get official sites
here's a couple physicists from Cora
when it says physics is certainly uh
it's certainly uh tries to explain how
the universe works explain okay physics
is the science which tries to understand
nature why and how Okay so uh you know
physics is
um you know an explanatory science a
discipline it had better be because
that's what physics is that's what
people want to know like if you go to
quora or you go to the stack exchange
another side and you'll go to
hyperphysics some of these places
they'll try to you know the questions
people ask them are always the same
another one how how stuff works people
want to know about physics and what do
you mean by that they don't want to have
an equation they want to say how does
this work how does gravity work you know
that's what I want you to tell me okay
how does uh magnetism work you know what
what causes right this to attract that
isn't that a question of physics or is
it question philosophy
now this is a question of physics people
want to know you know how this happens
physically okay so this is not a
question philosophy or any other
discipline for that matter no these are
questions of physics they want an
explanation of the mechanism and once
once we understand that we're done with
physics especially for all this
invisible stuff that no one has been
able to answer in mathematical physics
okay so what is an explanation well math
explanation is a theory that's what it
is that's what that's a synonym
the word theory and explanation are
synonyms theory is not a description
which is what mathematical physicists
you know mathematicians they made those
two words uh equal and that's not true
they're not synonyms okay so Theory a
system of ideas intended to what explain
something that's what Oxford languages
dictionary says theory is a carefully
thought out what explanation that's from
The Field Museum
uh Theory generalized explanations of
how nature works okay that's what a
theory is especially a theory of what
physics that's not a Wikipedia Theory a
plausible or scientifically acceptable
General principle or body of principles
offered to what explain phenomena
and the final world Cambridge dictionary
theory a formal statement of ideas that
are suggested what to explain
and that's what it is explanation and
Theory are synonyms okay a theory is not
a description math can only describe
therefore mathematics has no theories
whatsoever
that's why they talk about laws whatever
those are and then they kind of punch it
in there with theories say we have a
theory theory of general relativity
well the theory of general relativity is
not the equation that's just a
description the theory of general
relativity is what warp space
uh
uh what do you call it geometry the
geometry of space time that's different
than saying this is the equation
equation is just a description all that
an equation does is describe okay so
here we have
uh that these people speaking in tongues
okay someone says what causes the
pendant fall to the floor uh Einstein
right and a smart fellow there the
Einstein guy you know a disciple he says
the acceleration of gravity which is 9.8
meters per second Square yeah he gives
them a mathematical answer that's not
the question that was asked but they say
that this is what a theory is at least
the mathematicians believe that this is
the notion of what they call Theory no
no way theory is explanation okay an
explanation is not a description which
is the only thing that math can do okay
so here we have a couple uh uh official
sites okay and and we're going to look
at the uh words that they use okay the
language the vocabulary okay that these
people use and here's one Palm Beach
State College okay and you see all these
words and what you won't find in there
is words of physics what you find is
worth words of mathematics all these
words are mathematics and you say well I
can't go through all that let's simplify
this so that you can see it real easily
we'll take all the definitions out of
there we'll just leave the words okay so
there you see all the words okay and see
all those have to do with
um with mathematics has nothing at all
to do with physics with causes and with
mechanisms okay it turns out that if you
look up the definition of all these
words half of them at least okay here's
half of them they have the word object
in the definition
okay so all these words have the word
object and nowhere do you have the word
object defined
so this is the word so strange here
these people are saying that you need
the word object to Define all these
words of mathematics and not one of them
not not one uh word in there is the word
object not one uh defines the word
object or the word exists for that
matter physics is the science of
existence okay and they don't Define the
word exist either so neither object or
exist is on that list here you have
another site a famous one hyperphysics
and if you go to the right side of of
that
website you'll find all the words and
they have tons of words there not one of
them is a word of physics not one of
them uh includes the you know that list
does not include the word object or the
word exist
so how can you do physics without an
object is the question and why haven't
they find them
uh if if you go to high school or
college and you don't have to take
physics per se like you know a high
level I mean just an introductory course
you buy any textbook the physics out
there and just open it up and look at
the vocabulary or the glossary or
whatever
you will not find the word object ever
defined no mathematician in the last ten
thousand years after you find the word
object it turns out you can't do physics
without objects I mean how are you going
to explain a phenomenon a mechanism you
know what caused something to happen if
you don't have if you have defined a
word object you don't know what an
object is
and so this is interesting that this
crucial word has never been defined by
uh so-called physicist you know
mathematical physicists why because they
do math they don't do physics at all and
here's another side just in case okay in
a quintessential instructional archive
and again when you look in there you
find all these words of mathematics and
you don't find a single word of physics
not you won't find uh the word object or
the word exists what you'll find is uh
Words which are irrational such as
energy and mass okay I mean mass is not
irrational if you just say Quantity of
matter but they also say that uh mass is
inertia or measure of inertia or
whatever and that's when they screw it
up completely no it intercept has to do
with weight not with quantity of matter
quantity of matters you don't measure
you count and inertia you measure and
weight you measure Okay so
yeah your nurses are different it's like
the counterpart like I said the other
day of uh weight
okay so here we have uh because of that
you have sites like NASA and they don't
use the word gravity they they don't
Define the word gravity you say what is
gravity because that's that's what
they're trying to explain here they say
no we're going to tell you what gravity
is okay what is gravity it says uh
anything that has mass also has gravity
but you haven't told me what gravity is
what do you mean it has gravity like I
have 10 cents in my pocket like that it
has gravity objects with more mass have
more gravity
okay so they never tell you what gravity
is and then they have this ridiculous
you know little ball going around you
know the center of mass right and
Earth's gravity comes from all its mass
and again they just tell you where it
comes from they never tell you what
gravity is and these are the words that
people want to have answers to they want
to have a definition on the one hand and
they would like a mechanism they would
like to have an explanation a physical
interpretation they never get it okay
okay so um
where does this take us well all I can
do is give you the rational version the
scientific version okay and that's what
we contrast again this mathematical
language this uh irrational language
called mathematical physics
you know math is math physics is physics
never the twin shall meet uh math can
only describe physics is about
explanations about theories right
mechanisms causes
and you cannot explain with equations
with numbers with formulas which is what
math is about so math and physics never
will meet
and the first religion really to try to
merge them was geometry you know because
geometry has on the one hand the
triangle which belongs to physics
because it's an object it's a thing okay
why is it a thing because it has shape
that's the definition
and then they go in there and they say
let me tell you about angles
and they they're not talking about just
the qualitative angles like you know
this is perpendicular to that no they're
talking about how much how many degrees
okay uh inside you know for example
triangle the inside uh angles of a
Triangle Sum to 180 degrees okay that
sort of thing so they're concerned about
numbers and so they try to merge
uh quantities with quality with quality
and that's why they forgot about giving
qualitative explanations to phenomena
okay and yeah we say look for physics
you need a different kind of language
and it's a language that the
mathematicians never defined okay so
here we have physics causes and
mechanisms that's what physics is
explanations okay explanation of a
mechanism requires objects you know you
cannot explain a mechanism mechanism
causes right unless you have an object
you have to identify the object and if
it's an invisible object you still have
to identify it you know for example air
air is invisible
it's not an object it's not a thing
is there a concept no air is a physical
object sorry okay here's what blew your
house down uh fast there okay fast
moving air but air is the object the
thing okay that was in motion
okay so you need objects otherwise you
can't explain any mechanism and what
people want to understand in physics is
mechanisms okay the language of physics
is not mathematics
okay mathematics is what uh um
illustration you need to illustrate
yeah if you're gonna just give me the
illustration and I'll understand the
mechanism you can explain a little bit
there if you need to no problem but
physics is illustration you need to
illustrate
you know because you have objects you
had better be able to illustrate in
physics okay and all these people they
just want to talk about numbers that's
not an illustration that's just the
concept
that describes it you know in the
abstract mode an equation cannot tell
you what physical object is is doing the
acting well it plays the central role in
your theory okay so equation is
worthless in that sense
and so uh yeah we end up with this we
end up with the foundations of physics
the key words that you absolutely need
to Define in order to do physics what is
physics explanations physical
interpretations causes right mechanisms
that's what you need physics requires an
object so you absolutely need to define
the word object you can't do physics
without an object that's the first rule
what I call the golden principle of
physics okay
and there you have what I call the
foundations of physics which are the
words that you need to define the
vocabulary that you absolutely need to
do physics you cannot do physical
interpretations physics without these
words you absolutely need to Define
these words okay you cannot Escape that
and it's what is something well it's
that which has shape and there you have
a bunch of synonyms what is nothing
it's an antonym of something right the
opposite and what is that that which
doesn't have shape and then you have
some synonyms okay space it's an object
in space are antonyms
then you have to have distance you have
to show distance between any two objects
why because you're going to talk about
location which is the set of distances
from one object to all the others in the
universe or in your system whatever
system you're explaining uh exist
it's an object that has location meaning
distance with respect to all other
objects right God wants to be part of
that he's you better have distance with
respect to all the other objects and
since under our proposal there's a
single thread God had better be part of
the single thread otherwise we're not in
touch with him and he's not in touch
with us
is working action at a distance and
that's black magic
and you say well God can do that yeah he
can but I can't so if God wants to
communicate with me God have better do
something better something better than
uh black magic okay he may be all
powerful I'm not okay that's one issue
the other one issue is that you know God
has to touch me in some way
and he said well no he doesn't he he can
you know penetrate your brain and talk
to you in your brain uh without touching
your without entering your head or
whatever
well again if it's inside my brain it's
going to change the atoms in there the
way I think Etc he's got to do some
touching
there's no way he can avoid that we he
may work without touch I can't I need to
work through touch
okay so if he wants to change my mind
he's got to touch something in my head
Okay so
keep that in mind God God can be all
powerful all he wants but he's got to be
part of our universe I mean if he wants
to be part of our universe if he wants
to exist right at least for us uh he's
got to be part of the threat the single
threat okay he's got to be made out of
atoms and every one of his atoms has to
be connected to all other atoms
otherwise he's got black magic one issue
and the other one is that if God comes
down to earth he should be able to
explain to you how he
communicates or how he made something
out of nothing he can explain all that
you should be able to understand the
mechanism why not
you know I mean he can talk about
anything he can talk about the 26th
Dimension if if he wants you say well I
don't understand all that yeah you'll
understand
uh what he's trying to tell you okay
you'll get the overall picture so if God
wants to tell you that he made something
out of nothing you should be able to
understand it he should be able to
expand besides he's all powerful he
should know a way that he can explain it
to you in such a way that you would
understand it motion two or more
locations of an object and what is a
concept well it's a word that invokes or
embodies two objects or two words which
are momentarily treated as objects okay
and with that I'll see you next week
we'll see